ينضم الينا الان من عمان اللواء فايز
الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي قضيه
الصواريخ هذه تبدو معقده حضره الدواء ولكن
لنبدا على الاقل من هذا التشويش هل هل هذا
التشويس يعتبر انجاز روسي
نعم يعتبر انجاز لانه حد من قدرات هذه
الصواريخ الصواريخ يعني في كل حرب يظهر
اسلحه مفاجئه
ويستطيع الخصم ان يقلل من قدراتها
وامكاناتها باتخاذ بعض الاجراءات سواء
السلبيه او الايجابيه الان اذا ذهبنا الى
بدايه استخدامها فيشار حزيران الماضي قدمت
الشيء الكثير سواء في قصف منظومه الامداد
مستودعات الوقود مستودعات الذخيره دعم
القوات المهاجمه ولا ننسى العمليه
العسكريه السريعه في خارقه وبالتالي الذي
مهد لهذه العمليه وساهم في انجاحها كانت
صواريخ هاي مارس وبالتالي بسبب هذا
التاثير كان لزاما على روسيا الجيش الروسي
ان يتخذ اجراءات منها الايجابي ومنها
السلبي يسمى الدفاع السلبي والدفاع
الايجابي اما ما هو الدفاع السلبي او
الاجراء السلبي
حزمه التردد
طبعا هناك اجراءات واجراءات مضاده
ندخل في نظام القفز الالكتروني الى ما
شابه ذلك ولكن هناك اعتراف حقيقي من قبل
الجيش الروسي بالجيش الاوكراني بان فاعليه
ليست كما كانت في بدايه المعركه وهذا امر
متوقع
تسليط الضوء على صواريخ هيمارس كشف ما سمي
بتعديلات سريه على انظمتها بمعنى لا
تستطيع ان تذهب اكثر من مدى معين هل تعتقد
بان
القوات الاوكرانيه وقعت في نوع من التضليل
في هذا المجال
لا يا سيدي هي يعني هي اولا
هذه الراجمه اذا استخدم فيها الصاروخ
التقليدي مدى 80 كيلو متر 227 ملم قطره
هذا مصمم اصلا وهذا اقصى مدى يمكن ان يصله
ولكنها مزوده بحاضنه مستقله يستخدم فيها
الصاروخ الذي يصل مداه الى 300 كيلومتر
وهذا لم يتم تزويد الجانب الاوكراني به
وتم اجراء التعديل بحيث لا يمكن حتى لو
وجد صاروخ بديل يمكن
مواصفاته الفنيه
تتوافق مع متطلبات هذه الراجمه لا يمكن
استخدامه اي بمعنى اخر تم تعطيل جزء من
قدراتها من قبل امريكا قبل اجسادها هذا
التشويش الروسي هل
يقلل نوعا ما من هيبه هذا النوع من
الصواريخ
اجازه التعبير
لا اعتقد ذلك لانه هذا الامر حصل في يعني
اذا تطرقنا الى الحروف في المنطقه اثناء
العربيه في عام 56 كان عامل المفاجاه سلاح
سلاح الجو لم يستفد الجيش المصري من ذلك
ففي 67 اعيدت نفس الماسه وكان الرقم الصعب
سلاح الجو في عام 73
ظهر صاروخ التاو ولم نستطيع ان نستوعب هذه
الصدمه فبالتالي هو كان لاعبا رئيسيا في
عزمها لكن بالمقابل تمكن الجيش السوري
والجيش المصري من مفاجاه اسرائيل بمنظومه
صواريخ سام فلم تستطع ان تتجنب تاثيرها
خلال فتره الحرب ولكن فيما بعد استطاعت
ذلك اذا دعني اقول في كل حرب يكون هناك
سلاح جديد يحدث نوع من الصدمه ولكن اذا
طال امد الحرب هنا يتم البحث عن ايجاد
اليه سواء كما قلت لك بالدفاع السلبي او
الايجابي للحد من قدرات هذا السلاح شكرا
لك من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي